I just want to do something in the
afternoon you know something nice
nothing crazy
okay wait that's what Jennifer Lopez
told us about celebrating her 50th
birthday well nice nothing crazy has a
whole different meaning in JLo's world
you are absolutely right she lit up
Miami literally in a birthday blowout
for the ages and we are taking you
inside we stick it up to the ceiling
what is it involved we're going to a
Jennifer Lopez birthday party you know
it's just it's gonna be a big
celebration dancing or singing we're
having a good time it's my yeah and now
I know what to give a woman that doesn't
need anything a 50th birthday party that
has everything
a rod and an estimated 250 guests turned
it up on Gloria and Emilio Estefan 32
million dollars Star Island estate in
Miami and before we get into the
over-the-top party details let's just
take a moment to appreciate the glory of
that dress the custom gold cutout
Versace was greeting in the front and
bondage in the back
and it was made to get on the floor also
there ryan seacrest DJ Khaled Fat Joe
and Ashanti who took the mic for their
2002 party anthem but one of the
sweetest moments of the night came from
J Lo's 11 year old twins
[Music]
Emme and max both took the stage and
performed for their proud llama so how
much does a party like this cost get no
move on Ness easy man Metis experts
estimate the price tag could have been
upwards of 1 million dollars et has
learned that this 10 tiered cake alone
cost more than 10,000
as for the genuinely heartfelt speech
delivered by a rod well that's priceless
remember that ring had a price tag it's
a day more than a million dollars show
of love whoo and Jennifer is going to be
celebrating another big birthday on
Saturday tables are turning Alex is
turning 44 and Saturday is also the
final date of her tour in Miami so will
they just take this whole party on to
the stage my guess would be yes
[Applause]
[Music]